apple just released their brand new air
tags and today we're gonna see
how do they compare to their biggest
competitors we have
the tile pro these were the first ones
in the game and then of course their
biggest
rival in the smartphone game samsung and
their
smart tag and we're going to be
comparing things such as the features
the size and weight the loudness of the
speakers which you can't you know tell
based upon spec sheet
and also the range where you can
actually find them and then how long it
takes
for a different phone to actually pick
up one of these devices
so you know approximately how long
you'll have to wait if you lose your
item
and we'll see how the networks with
these devices compare
now believe it or not the air tags are
actually the least expensive
out of the bunch you can buy one for 29
compared to 30 dollars with samsung
smart tag or 35
for tile but then if you buy a four pack
they come in at 25 dollars
each if you buy a four pack of the tile
they actually drop down to that same 25
which is competitive
but samsung's they didn't used to have a
four pack they're offering it now but
there's no price
listed now along with that air tags is
the only one that has a u1 chip built in
we'll talk about that in just a bit
samsung is coming out with a better
version of this that will also have that
u1 chip or the ultra wide band
to help you find it but that one's going
to cost 40
let's go and see how the tile compares
as far as
size and weight so wow as far as
thickness it actually seems
a little bit thinner but of course you
guys can see the size difference the
tile is
definitely larger has a much bigger
footprint if i put the air tag on top
you guys notice
the difference right there all right
let's open up our smart tag
and it seems to be somewhere in the
middle it's actually a little bit
thicker now actually noticeably thicker
than the air tag we got a button there
and size wise it is bigger than the
air tag but not as big footprint wise as
tile now one obvious difference is that
the air tag while it's smaller it
doesn't have a little cutout
for your key ring so you can't just
directly attach it
without an accessory so as you guys see
i have my other air tag here
and i had to buy one of these
accessories i actually bought a ton of
them for my ear tags
so i do like this belkon the best it is
the least expensive that apple sells
and it keeps the footprint fairly small
and it's the closest to your actual
keychain
if you were to attach both the tile does
take up still
more room than this belkin but then the
air tag does end up costing more
now as far as battery life they are very
similar
for a year whereas a samsung is actually
rated for 300 days or about 300 days
in order to swap the battery uh you
actually have to get a tool in here
which seems kind of scary like i'm gonna
break something
there you go all of them actually use
the same exact battery
and then on the tile you actually just
grip it and then pull
the section down and bam same exact
battery and these batteries are very
inexpensive you can get a four pack for
about five bucks
or there's actually a 100 pack on amazon
for 17 bucks i'll
link them down below and now let's go
ahead and pair up
these smart trackers we're going to
start out with the air tag
all you do is pull on the little tab
when you take the
little plastic off and bam right there
it's close to our phone
and i can choose what i want this to be
so let's say this is going to be for
my bike and bam that is
how easy it is to set up your air tag
here's the other tags that i have
set up already now for tile of course
you do have to download
the tile app and then you're gonna have
to set up an account and up
bam activating tile there you go
that is done and we'll just select keys
for it and check this out it's actually
telling me right away to try to find my
phone
by using the button so i'm going to
double press on the logo
there you go so if you have your keys
with you you don't have your phone you
want to find it
double press even if it's on silent mode
you'll actually be able to find your
phone it will play that audio
and premium this is where other things
come in
with tile if you want all their features
which it does actually have some extra
smart features such as notifications if
you leave
an item behind which air tags do not
currently have
you can pay for it looks like it's about
100 bucks if you pay for a full
year oh so looks like the s21 ultra did
find
the smart tag so let's go ahead and add
that so that's another level of
convenience
if you have a samsung phone and bam we
are finished so tile is definitely uh
the toughest to
set up or at least the longest process
since it's not built into these phones
and it looks like now we have to wait
for a software
update which i haven't seen with tile or
with air tag now when we double tap it
you can hear the phone going off now we
can find our phone
let's dismiss that the other cool thing
is that
this can actually be used as a remote to
do other tasks so right here
you can choose between pressing on it
and holding on it
and then if you have a bunch of other
samsung accessories
then you can actually control them but
that is a nice little extra bonus
if you're going to go with samsung's
option and now i want to compare the
volume
of the trackers themselves if you're
going to be searching for something
let's go ahead and start out with the
air tag
okay so i was actually quite surprised
the first time i heard it that was
fairly quiet
that actual frequency and the way it
modulates it does help you find it from
a distance
uh but now let's go ahead and do
samsung's smart tag
all right that is definitely louder i'm
sure you guys can tell through the
microphone
definitely louder than the air tag and
then let's switch over to
our tile app all right come on
oh there you go huh that is quieter than
the smart thing so with that it looks
like the air tag has the least amount of
options you can't switch your ringtone
you can't adjust the volume
you don't have a button that you can
press and it does seem to be quieter
than the other two it's not that much
quieter than the tile but it definitely
is
in third place it does have one benefit
though um the fact that it's completely
sealed
so uh it's actually waterproof you can
submerge it for one meter up to 30
minutes
whereas the other two are splash proof
and that makes sense because
you have the design where you have
speakers open you have little covers
to open up compared to this kind of
completely sealed design
so now i'm going to have angelica go and
hide it in the other room she'll put
them in three different spots
and then i'll try to find it thank you
angelica for hiding them
before i go look for them um i'm gonna
just play the sound from here i'm about
25 feet away that's in a different room
with the door closed so let's play the
air tag first
okay i can clearly hear it and i clear
that it's from that direction
the weird thing about the air tags is
they're not that loud but the frequency
that it plays it's really easy to kind
of pick it up
next let's go ahead and switch over to
the tile and i'll press that
well surprisingly it could also be the
frequency that's a lower tone
and it doesn't really modulate it's just
different beeps so loudness sounds about
the same from that distance
compared to the air tag where here it
was definitely louder and then lastly
let's try out the smart tag
definitely louder yeah definitely louder
so it's louder on the table is
definitely louder over there as well
and now let's go ahead and pick this up
and let's go look
we got too many things here but we'll
make it through
all right
in here why are you stopping playing
let me set the samsung phone down and
yes guys we have too much stuff in here
no no that's over here where is it
in this spot oh there it is that was
weird it was almost like it bounced off
the walls that sound
and it's kind of confusing of course we
have that fine feature
which we'll show you in just a sec all
right we got that one let's switch over
to the tile
it always takes the longest to connect
sounds like a kid's cell phone
all right
[Music]
oh nice and loud
definitely nice and loud probably about
twice as loud compared to the other ones
and that little curve stops it from
being blocked if it's laying somewhere
so that was definitely easy and now
let's test out the killer feature of the
air tag angelica go ahead and grab this
hide it one more time and we'll use that
find feature
all right so that's hidden i'm gonna hit
this find button on my phone
it connected right away it says i'm 11
feet away
10 feet away getting closer and now i
get this nice little notifications on me
where to go and if i need to turn or not
to your right ahead all right and i'm
also getting haptic so the phone's
vibrating as i'm getting closer if i go
the other way it kind of
uh the pulse changes to your left
all right so all right let's see
getting further away getting closer
did you put it up here somewhere do you
like to see me struggle
do you like that i thought
it's all one oh so it was right there
yeah so that is really cool so if you're
close enough
you're not too far away it will
literally guide you to the air tag and
then when you get that close you can
always hit that speaker button
now before we do our ultimate test
seeing how long it's going to take for
these trackers to be found
when we put them into lost mode i want
to see how far away can you be
and still connect to the actual tracker
tile gives us its actual range they say
400 feet but apple doesn't actually list
anything so i'm curious
is the range better than tile or is it
maybe a lot
worse so i'd say i'm about 300 feet away
i can't go all the way back to 400
because it ends right over there
we're taking a look first at the air tag
and let me hit find it says connection
connected signal is weak try moving to a
different location
and now i've lost the signal so looks
like we're a little bit too far
for the air tag now let's go over to
tile
let's hit find wow connected it says the
signal strength is strong
and i actually hear it from all the way
over there now let's take a look at our
smart tag over here
we're saying it's saying that it's
connecting the status is
nearby see if we can play a sound
oh i hear it once again and now i'm at
250 feet let's go ahead and see if it
can play a sound
yep it is playing and i can hear it but
it is not as loud as the other trackers
and now i'm on the opposite side of our
office building one story away from ours
and i went ahead and tried to play the
sound and connect to the air tag
and unfortunately it is not connecting
all it says it just tries to connect and
says i'm too far away
so air tag is not reachable but then
when i go over
to the tile app it does take a little
bit to connect
and then it actually does connect and it
says that the signal strength is
moderate
and it's playing that sound and as far
as the samsung smart tag
it did actually connect it says the
status is
nearby and it will allow me to actually
play
the volume and play the sound so i can
go find it so it looks like
both the smart tag and the tile they
both have similar strengths
as far as the reception of the distance
to get to your tracker
but the air tag is in third place and
now
for our ultimate test we are going to
put these trackers
into their lost modes and see how long
it takes
for the network to find our lost device
all right guys i went to the busiest
place that i can think of and that is
the mall it is a friday evening the
parking lot is pretty much
packed and i put all three trackers in
front of the front doors
in the bushes there and there's
constantly people coming in and coming
out
um and then i left the phones in
airplane mode when i left the office so
they wouldn't connect to them
and now i'm gonna drive away and we're
gonna put these things in lost mode
so looks like the air tag was found
for some reason i didn't get a
notification but in the app it says it
was found
five minutes ago i'm at home now after
doing some shopping and it looks like
both the tile and the samsung were just
found
that took about 40 and 45 minutes
compared to 15
for the air tag of course that is a
really busy area and that's how long it
took if you're
losing it somewhere else the chances of
you finding it is slimmer
which is why air tags are kind of better
having a huge network of iphones
personally i was expecting the air tax
to do the best but surprisingly it
didn't in a lot of these
categories but of course if you're
keeping your stuff indoors
you're not actually losing it you're
just trying to find things having that
find my feature
or find your device where it actually
guides you is really really cool and
really helpful
i have links to all of these down in the
description below if you guys want to go
and pick one up
and we also have the ultimate video
where we
take one of these air tags apart and we
go and do the find my feature we try out
all the accessories
and tell you which ones are most worth
it you guys can check that out right
over there
and along with that we're gonna have the
third party accessory video as well that
you guys want to check out so click that
circle above to subscribe
and help us to reach 1 million
subscribers before the end of the year
this one max and i'll see you
in the next video
[Music]